for many parts of the country summer is
mosquito season familiar buzz alone may
be enough to make you start scratching
but one company is releasing 20 million
mosquitoes into a California
neighborhood in the name of science the
people behind the experiment in Fresno
hope it actually reduces the mosquito
population only on CBS this morning
Mireya Villarreal is the first Network
horse on it to go inside the
one-of-a-kind lab in South San Francisco
she learned how it could help scientists
fight some of the world's deadliest
diseases it's just after sunrise in
Fresno California and this van circling
a residential neighborhood is making a
rather unusual delivery it's hard to see
with the naked eye but flying out of
this tube are thousands of mosquitoes
new additions to the community are the
mosquitos gonna bother us are gonna bite
us but so far it hasn't been much of a
problem it's not a problem for homeowner
Bonnie Smith because despite putting
more bugs in the air the experiment in
this van could actually decrease the
mosquitoes in her backyard the only ones
we release our male mosquitos which
don't bite only the females bite and the
males were releasing are sterile so when
they meet with the wild female she'll
still produce and lay eggs but they'll
never hatch each tray has three thousand
mosquitoes Linus Upson is running this
experiment for verily the life sciences
corporate cousin of tech powerhouse
Google in total they're releasing a
million mosquitoes a week for 20 weeks
this summer so you are going to release
20 million mosquitoes in the Fresno area
our neighbors not concerned about this
once people understand that male
mosquitoes don't bite and that if we're
successful we're going to reduce the
population the mosquitoes that do bite
them people are usually thrilled the
wild mosquitoes do more than bite the
breed verily is targeting 80s a gypped I
also spread some of the world's most
dangerous diseases including dengue
fever and Zika if we release enough of
them for a long enough period of time we
hope we can eliminate the population of
80s gypped I'm
he knows near where people live to do
that verily has spent millions of
dollars building this lab which breeds
sterilizes and rears millions of bugs
then sorts them by sex to ensure only
the males are released producing a
million male mosquitoes a week it's
quite a feat Jody Holman works for a
local government run mosquito control
program they tried a smaller scale
version of this last summer but only
released 800,000 pests now partnered on
this project with the deep pockets of
Google they're able to multiply that by
a factor of 25 we really needed to have
the ability to rear the number of males
that would be needed to affect control
but partnering with the Google family of
companies comes with its own
complications I always have a concern
when Google says it's gonna do anything
John Simpson of the nonprofit consumer
watchdog has kept a close eye on Google
and its subsidiaries for years he sees
nothing wrong with the science and
safety of the fresno experiment it's
what comes next that concerns him in the
future if they've got all the
proprietary information you have to meet
their terms and if because of their
powerful position they can essentially
dictate those terms you then end up
being at the valley's mercy we don't
know exactly how we're gonna go to
market with this as a business right now
we're just focused on showing that it
can work if it works the project could
serve as a model for other communities
around the world
and even though dengue fever and Zika
aren't threatening fresno people here
don't seem to mind acting as test
subjects for technology that could save
millions of lives in the future in a way
it's sort of neat to be a part of it in
one small way
researchers in Fresno are monitoring
traps throughout these neighborhoods and
are hoping to see a drop in mosquito
populations by the end of this summer
for CBS this morning midday ovule San
Francisco mosquitoes killed so many
people across this planet any kind of
technology that can help alleviate the
impact of malaria especially among the
young devastating absolutely